foreign
Virginia Beach Hooked on Phonics worked
for me what's up Shay
hey John how are you today I'm not
speaking very clearly but other man I'm
doing great what's happening I can't
either
nothing too much I was just hoping to
pick your brain today on the mental
health of law students so not great not
great all right so it's actually not for
me
um as a wife of a law student how can I
help and protect my husband's mental
health so and I can give some
backgrounds yeah give me some background
Okay so
it's the first time away from family and
friends that he's known you know his
whole life so that's going to be a big
adjustment
um we're going into the first year law
school so he starts this month
um and my biggest concern is that he's
had a history of anxiety and depression
last year he went through like two
months that was pretty deep and that was
like his biggest
um bout of anxiety and depression and he
got checked out by the doctor went to a
therapist got a lot of tools to get
better and went continued and improved
from there and we never had issues since
then but now we're in a place where
there's actual Seasons we're from
Florida so
winter doesn't happen so I'm kind of
concerned about seasonal depression and
you know first year of marriage and law
school's hard so just what are some tips
and insight that you have from your
experience that myself my husband and us
together can Implement so his mental
health is intact over this next couple
of years oh man all right so
I got a lot I got a lot of opinions is
that okay okay that's fine probably what
I'm gonna do is I'm just gonna start
rattling off a bunch of things and you
can just pull this clip and y'all can
watch it together okay okay
um
because it'll probably be too much just
to write down while you're on the phone
um so you know I was a dean of students
at a law school and my research was in
the mental health of attorneys and so I
spent
um
in the academic world whether it was
professional conferences or academic
conferences like I lived and breathed
the mental health of lawyers and law
students that was my that was my thing
for years okay and so
um
it's incredible that y'all are this much
on on the front end of this
most of the time a newlyweds Waltz into
the law school everybody's excited I
married a lawyer it's gonna be great and
then about four months into school
everything falls apart okay so here's um
here's number one he has to this is a no
if ands or buts he has to get Mental
Health Resources before school starts
okay that can be through the university
that can be through a local counselor
it's worth the money even if you don't
have it
and I tell you that because law school
is very very hard
and it's hard both academically but it's
hard in a way that if
it's competitive too which makes it
really challenging because it's not just
a matter of learning the material it's
learning the material better than the
person next to you
and more thoroughly and that just adds a
level of of complexity and challenge to
this that is very different than any
other
um academic endeavor
thankfully his law school is actually a
Christian law school and so their the
competitiveness is a lot lower and
they're more supportive so we're in the
best situation that we can be for law
school I may do like
yeah well I would tell you like even if
it's a faith-based law school I hope
it's competitive because what here's the
deal I I don't want an attorney
that is not competitive taking care of
me if I get hit by a big trucking
company and their attorney went to NYU
and knows how to fight and Claw and
scratch I don't want a nice attorney
representing me you know what I mean
they're gonna get squashed and so
hopefully maybe pedagogically they're
changing like the the instruction there
is some literature that suggests that
competitive does not help that
competitive competition does not help
people learn at all in fact it restricts
learning
um and so there is maybe that's what
they're going after but I hope he's not
going into a law school that's just like
um patchy on the back I hope it's super
super rigorous because he's gonna be
representing clients that need him to be
an assassin that's what that's what
that's what a lawyer does right fights
your client he's got that fire but yes
so the challenge most people are caught
off guard by this they walk into law
school and they were really really smart
they're the smartest kids in their class
in other areas not always but often
law school is not something you can just
study for the night before right you
start worry studying for finals the
first day of class
and so as his wife you need to know that
when he says he's busy this is unlike
anything you'll have ever experienced
like read
the Harry Potter book every single night
for the whole semester right and that
only know that but know every character
and be able to know what that character
was about to do when a professor calls
on you and has you stand up and talk for
45 minutes on what that character was
doing so it's not even a matter of just
getting through the reading like all of
us did in undergrad this is about
internalizing it and knowing it okay so
I tell you that to tell you many
um
many husbands and wives and girlfriends
and boyfriends of law students and
lawyers
don't have a context for just how hard
this is and so they start to feel left
out like they're exaggerating like
they're kind of lying it is that hard
okay it is that hard the third thing
I'll tell you is you need to get a group
of friends ASAP
I know God you gotta have a gang because
if you're just sitting at home like
where is he where is he where is he and
then he comes home and he looks like
he's just gotten beaten up and you're
like hey let's go do this and this you
need to paint the bedroom and do that
it's gonna blow everything up so you got
to have a group of friends that that
gives you that connectivity that outlet
because there's gonna be some gaps in
your relationship just because his focus
is going to be on law school it's gonna
be hard yeah okay and I'm also a
studying actuary so I have to study for
big exams too so I'll be studying with
them but not as much as he is you're an
actuary I am oh your your dinner table
conversations are going to be riveting
yes you're just riveting is he going
into contract a lot please say yes no he
wants criminal ah I was gonna say y'all
would be the single healthiest most
boring couple that's ever lived but alas
oh he's totally more exciting than I am
that's okay he needs you in his life
desperately
um desperately all right here's the last
thing I'm going to tell you
um
I want you all to and this is going to
sound awful and very not cool for for
some first uh first year of marriage
okay okay I want you all to put dates
and sex on the calendar
okay build it into your life
build intimacy into your world because
if you wait for it just to happen like
most newlywed couples do they get shoved
in a one-bedroom apartment and they're
like hey you're gonna watch Netflix I
don't know how you want to make out like
that won't happen in y'all's lives
because you're every minute of y'all's
lives are gonna be so prescribed already
okay and
um
law school is an intimate
um it's an intimate Endeavor what does
that mean that means you're talking
about murder cases and rape cases and
you're talking about
um uh people who are hurting the
conversations are deep and talking about
ethics it's very common for people to
fall head over heels for somebody
because you're talking about deep things
that you never talk with anybody else in
the whole wide world
it's a deep exchange of ideas it's not a
thing to be scared of it's a thing for
y'all two to know we are going to
prioritize us over all this other crap
okay and we're gonna put stuff on the
calendar we always go to breakfast every
Saturday no matter what we always go on
a date every Saturday night no matter
what we always we start Tuesday nights
and Thursday nights for all year like
whatever y'all do but we're gonna put it
on the calendar and we're gonna do our
best especially that first year to not
not budge from it we're going to put it
even if it's perfunctory and we just got
to get through tonight we're gonna put
on the calendar and we're gonna make it
a part of our Lives because we're going
to we are never going to forget that the
main thing in both of our Lives is us
and if I got to quit law school to
preserve us I'm going to quit Law School
and if I've got to stop playing with
Actuarial tables I'm going to stop doing
that because this is about us is that
here what I'm saying and then the final
final thing is if at all possible
stay away from alcohol both of you
okay just stay away
um a few things in the world get law
students into more trouble than alcohol
okay like when I look at all the issues
um distilling down one of the key
factors was that and it usually starts
with and again he's gonna be at a
faith-based law school so it may be it
may be more limited there
um and it's been several years since I
was going to work in a law school it's
been five or six years since I was there
but
um alcohol just was was at every event
every everything all the time everywhere
globally just across the culture it's
just it's just pervasive in that culture
um and so having different types of
outlets different ways of having fun
different ways of connecting to other
people just keep a close close eye on
that stuff
that sound all right
so much for your input let me say one
more thing
this is supposed to be hard and our
culture needs brilliant hard smart
lawyers
and so I tell you all this stuff to tell
you not to scare you away to not sit
down tonight and be like I don't want
you to go to law school not that because
we need lawyers and I need people to
clean sewers and I need people who are
um work in the who do work at funeral
homes I need police officers we need
people to do hard jobs teachers
but that means we have to create a
culture we have to create a life so they
can repel in and do those hard jobs and
so it's not to scare you away from it I
want you guys to go do this I want you
guys to be well and whole and have a
great marriage on the back end which is
a hundred percent possible
I I had dinner with two of my former law
students the other day Jefferson and CJ
two amazing men who are married to
amazing women if they were with in law
school great great you just got to be on
top of it you got to talk it through and
you got to be a highly highly
intentional highly intentional amazing
let me know how he does first semester
uh we'll be rooting for him man that's
awesome and Shay he's really really
lucky to have you in his corner thank
you for loving him and thinking through
this way way in advance that's amazing